ricour alors j'ai relevé une opposition
entre deux ouvrages plus d'une heure
quelques vous paraît donc de la
révolution libérale et dès les premières
elles restent à faire oui dès les
premières pages là au contraire vous
vous intégrez vous parlez de
mystification libéral et de comédies
libéral mais absolument absolument et
voyez vous je veux du coup dire monsieur
au maroc quand il dit c'est un ouvrage
génère c'est un ouvrage utopiste et que
nous n'avons pas à nous plaindre des
libertés d'abord une première
observation des libertés quand il s'agit
de vous bernard pivot de vous de moi
aussi bien c'est aisé parce que nous
sommes dans cette société des personnes
qui ont leur place saleh la mesure des
libertés ça se prend au regard des plus
défavorisés d'une société pas des plus
favorisés donc ville avait déjà très
bien remarqué que je disais à propos de
l'ancien régime que si on était
bourgeois à reims au xviiie siècle bien
ma foi on se sentait assez en sécurité
en liberté pas celui qui ne trouvait pas
de travail et qui connaissait le grand
enfermement
alors vous nous dites ça fait généreux
ça fait comtesse de ségur un peu importe
eh bien je vais vous le dire parce que
dans la partie qui s'appelle nous tous
nous reprenons nous en compte les
déshérités et très simplement parce que
dans notre société monsieur il y à un
modèle c'est l'adulte installé
respectable producteurs et peut-être
directeur de quelque chose mais si vous
partez de ce modèle et que vous écartez
en cercles concentriques et bien d'un
seul coup vous alliez les fourbes ses
libertés
vous avez d'abord parce qu'il antique en
condition en droit mais quand même pas
les femmes
si vous descendez vous avez les malades
puis vous avez les handicapés puis vous
avez les vieillards puis vous avez les
étrangers puis si vous poursuivez vous
avez les détenus et si vous terminez les
skis pire que tous les internés et alors
cela nous les prenons en compte
c'est vrai ils nous disent on s'est
nourri chez nous alors vous appelez ça
généreux vous aimez sa comtesse de ségur
non je vais simplement que les
programmes simplement la première exil à
vivre en liberté
les libéraux les réaliser prend leur
mesure je lis encore lui de regarder
plus défavorisés alors en ce qui
concerne la révolution - mais toujours
appris je reviens à les données
élémentaires
malo que la révolution ça consistait à
faire passer ce qui était dessous dessus
vous à consiste à revenir en arrière
ceux que vous êtes les libertés ça n'est
même pas le maintien de l'ordre c'est le
retour en arrière même les réformes
modestes qu'on propose vous font hors et
voyez vous c'est pour ça que dans notre
livre nous parlons de la mystification
libéral aujourd'hui on vient vous dire
nous sommes les champions de la liberté
avec un grand l île et regardez
l'histoire la liberté avec un grand l en
réalité les libertés dont se targue
aujourd'hui les champions de la liberté
elles ont toujours été arrachés dans
l'histoire à ceux qui aujourd'hui
seraient les défenseurs de la liberté
pour avoir les libertés de la presse
il faut une insurrection apparaît en
1830 pour passer du suffrage censitaire
au suffrage universel
il faut une révolution en 19 48 lots 18
et lorsque vous en êtes aux droits
économiques et sociaux j'en parlais
l'autre jour avec mauroy à lille
combien d'hommes sont morts pour le
droit de grève aujourd'hui vous dites
mais comment c'est à qui s'est acquis
grâce à qui
grâce au module herth et à ceux et à
l'action les pays devaient relier avec
elle il n'y a qu'un sens de l'histoire
les libertés on les gagne et on les
gagne toujours contre ceux qui sont les
champions de l'aude et quand je vous
écoute et bien je puis vous dire vous
auriez été ultra polignac
vous auriez été notable ce guizot et
vous auriez des versaillais soutière jeu
de l'interview